in 2012 superstorm sandy pummeled the
east coast of America
winds blew in at 80 miles per hour and
heavy rain pushed the ocean over 9 feet
above average levels in New York storm
surges brought 30-foot waves ashore
flooding streets Subway's and homes 20
miles south of Manhattan several
neighborhoods on the small borough of
Staten Island sat in ruins homes were
completely leveled and 24 people were
killed as global temperatures rise
research has shown that increasingly
violent storms will likely continue
assaulting our coasts paired with rising
sea levels that could mean higher risk
of flooding and worsening catastrophic
damage to areas like this unless we
learn to adapt and for Staten Island
that means building a wall this idea
that we are physically remaking our
cities to make sure that they are going
to be resilient in the climate disasters
of the future and that will also include
retrofitting our cities for the everyday
effects of climate change which means
things like extreme heat heavy downpours
droughts a seawall is one of these
adaptations
it's erected parallel to the coast to
create a hard shoreline it deflects
daily tides to keep the shore from a
rotting away as it would under normal
conditions if a natural disaster strikes
it's meant to stop incoming storm surges
or even a tsunami
now if fortifying our cities with walls
seems too simple and a bit medieval
that's because it kind of is climate
change isn't a single assault on a
castle it's an ongoing worsening crisis
in in order to evolve with that crisis
the adaptations we make need to include
resilient infrastructure resiliency is
this idea that your city can respond to
any type of threat it might not just be
a climate threat but that you plan for
disasters and emergencies in a way that
will enrich everyday life for your
residents anyway in other words building
resilient infrastructure means we don't
have to choose between feeling safe and
enjoying our cities for example in 2008
New York Harbor schools start at the
billion oyster project a resiliency plan
that restores oyster reefs in New York
Harbor the reefs help filter the water
and slow down powerful waves preventing
erosion and reducing
the project is even doubling as an
education program for students around
the city when natural solutions like
that aren't enough cities may look for
more intense options like sea walls in
hopes to prevent another sandy level
disaster Staten Island has recently
received 615 million dollars in funding
for its own seawall the structure will
span about five miles and set twenty
feet above sea level and it includes
resilient design elements the wall will
double as a boardwalk making it far less
imposing and allowing residents to enjoy
the coastal views plus to keep Staten
Island safe the plan includes
adaptations to the land surrounding the
seawall globally rainfall during major
storms is expected to increase 20% by
2100 since much of Staten Island was
initially built on wetlands intense
rainfall could easily flood
neighborhoods something a seawall can't
prevent so the resiliency plan includes
returning several areas in the island to
their natural Murphy state and that
helps to mitigate that storm surge we
have that coastal flooding when you have
heavy rain and make sure that the water
is not going to be trapped in where the
buildings are several man-made ponds
will also be excavated for drainage
purposes these alterations require
careful planning and analysis of the
lands they're trying to defend and
altogether they make a pretty well
rounded protection plan but even with a
multi-faceted and resilient approach
these adaptations might not be enough in
2018 Norland finished an upgrade on sea
walls and levees designed to protect the
city but 14 billion dollars later
engineers are saying the walls will be
inadequate in four years due to sea
level rise and sinking land and on the
coast of Kerala India sea walls have
actually led to worsening coastal
erosion climate change can be
unpredictable and we're being put in a
position to predict it anyway resilient
infrastructure is one way to tackle that
uncertainty but it's not foolproof any
type of infrastructure we are building
to save ourselves from the adverse
impacts of climate change is also going
to introduce changes to our city that we
are going to have to learn to live with
it's moving beyond just
this one piece of infrastructure that
would stay there for a century or two
and really figuring out how you can
innovate on the materials and the design
over time to address different
challenges that will surface the reality
is that even with resiliency in mind
walling off the ocean is a band-aid
solution on a growing wound building a
wall to protect our cities is one thing
building our cities to protect
themselves is another hey you probably
realize this piece was a collaboration
between Fox and curbed and that's
because while I love making videos on
urbanism I really needed their expertise
on resilient infrastructure to make it
happen I actually linked to some of
their articles below that helped inspire
this video but they give you a more
in-depth analysis on sea walls and how
to build a resilient city in our
changing world curb covers everything
from urbanism to transportation to
housing so definitely go check them out
for more content and for more
information and updates on the staten
island seawall head over to curbed New
York